先给愿意激进自己的各位一个热烈的掌声
那今天活动的流程呢是由老师先分享交易心法
那再来是由我会工商开户服务的时间
那这个时候不可以偷跑
然后接下来呢是大家可以接下来问问题或者是拍照的一些询问
那五点前的话我们会准时擅长
那虽然我们在期货市场呢身经百战
但期货真正的
但交易的真正核心武器不是感觉
而是最扎实的数学、几率和期望值
今天我们要运到这位老师
就是能把这些复杂的数学工具
转化成最实用的交易逻辑大师
电竹医生马克洋老师
他深知数学是交易的本质
期货只是他的表现形式
他能用最扎实的数学功底
帮大家把交易中的不确定性
变成可计算的风险
今天的的讲座就是帮大家交易头脑进行系统升级
不是凭感觉的交易者
而是进化成懂计算的专业玩家
请大家用最热烈的掌声
欢迎我们的重量级讲师
马克洋老师
好,嗨,大家好
谢谢大家今天来
然后我们这次不是办在群艺期货
就是在外面租了一个可以有200个人可以坐下的场地
然后还是做的满满的
所以还是蛮开心的
然后
好,我今天要讲的主题是
关于我是怎么用游戏漏洞玩各式各样不同的游戏的
然后
所以也不只是讲低风险高报酬的事件交易
可能还是有一些些人不认识我
而且我们有录影
所以我还是简单的自我介绍一下
就是我以前是建宗术与自由班
然后后来读医学系毕业
然后现在没有再当医生了
现在就是玩各式各样的游戏
然后在高中的时候
我有拿过一次科学奥林匹亚的金牌跟世界冠军
那个就是一个比每个国家派出自己国家最会考试的小朋友
然后各个高中生比赛谁比较会考试的一个游戏
对
然后当时有代表台湾拿到金牌
但也不只是我厉害
就是通常台湾派去的人都非常厉害
因为我们亚洲的血统就是非常擅长这些
通常什么亚洲的新加坡台湾啊日本啊
这些都是非常厉害
然后
然后因为我是医生嘛
所以就有医生制造
然后阳正数学
以前也有当过补习班老师
然后有做过一些这个跟朋友
帮助朋友的创业项目
卖金磨枪的一个公司
然后因为我今天讲的都还是跟投资比较有关系啊
就是我以前还有当过什么舞台剧演员啊
或是游泳池的救生员之类的
就是我的
其实我想要做的是学会各式各样的全部的事情
对
所以就是现在学习股票期货玩这个游戏之后
我以后应该还是会再继续学更多的东西
比如说学法律啊
学各式各样新的东西
好
然后因为我们今天讲的是一个游戏嘛
就是股票期货
一个猜数字的游戏
所以我也来讲一下我的游戏经历
那
比较多人认识我
其实我大部分的观众应该都是
我玩炉石的时候认识我的
就是马克洋也是玩炉石的时候的一个名字这样
好
然后后来最近
今年有在玩Shadowverse 2
然后也有成功达到天梯第一
然后还有下围棋啊
然后今年有去21点算牌
等一下会讲
就是算是我今年新学的
而且做了一个我自己觉得满满意的一件事情这样
然后我是一个很特别的玩家类型
我是一个游戏漏洞玩家
就是我很擅长用数学和心理学的各种理论来寻找各个游戏里面的游戏漏洞
然后心理学就包括行为经济学、读心术啊
这些是我比较有兴趣觉得比较好玩的东西
然后游戏漏洞指的是
没有犯规
遵守游戏规则的情况下去找到低风险高报酬的游戏机会
就是如果是像是在台湾
内线交易是犯规的
就是它违反法律
但是根本就不会被抓
所以它是低风险高报酬
但是这样有犯规
所以这个就不叫游戏漏洞
这个就是犯规了
当然犯规也其实不会怎样
犯规的话就是
受到道德的内心良心谴责
大概就只是这样子而已
不过反正我们当然还是希望
我们是有受到这个士大夫精神
对我们还是要尽量遵守游戏规则的情况下玩
对
所以我尽量都还是
我还是很在乎要遵守游戏规则
我觉得这样子这个世界
比较和谐
好
然后
所以像21点算牌就算是一种游戏规则的漏洞
它是1962年
就是已经好几十年前的数学家发现
就是这样玩21点
你只要记得某一个表科
你就会迎走赌场
非常非常多的钱
然后是没有违反游戏规则的
那像这种就是属于游戏漏洞
那所以游戏漏洞并不一定要是都没有人知道的事情
例如说21点算牌就是一个超级多人都知道的游戏漏洞
那只是因为这个游戏实在是太受欢迎了
所以赌场还是继续使用这些游戏
因为赌场相信大部分的玩家都没有办法学会数学
然后如果他辨识出那些人是会数学的
他就把它Band掉
以后不给他玩
对就是这样子
所以这个21点仍然在拉斯维加是非常的盛行
好
然后呢
所以我今天要讲的真正的主题
会再用
希望用更高的层级来带大家理解
就是游戏漏洞玩家的
这样的一个很特殊的制定策略方式
那希望大家以后再参与各式各样的游戏
当然也包括股票期货的时候
可以就是学会制定自己的游戏方式
这样
就是学习一些思考的方式
我们用更general的方式来学习
那当然有一部分也是因为就是
以前我的讲座都会直接讲
那个付费等级的期货交易策略
但是呢
这个
现在公司会有一些要求
就是如果是付费等级的教学内容的话
不可以再免费讲座讲
那我觉得这也算是一种合理的要求
所以就是你们可能以前也看过我YouTube上面
有很多免费的期货教学
那现在也都先暂时把它隐藏掉了
那不过就是虽然今天不能直接讲那种很明确的
这个期货的策略
但是我会讲很多
我认为还是非常有趣的事情
就是在很多跟还是跟金钱游戏有关的地方
然后大家可以就是学到很多很有趣的事情
好
我们第一个还是先讲
跟这个股票的期货选择权有关
就是台风价事后的选择权
这个也是我公开分享过很多次的一个策略
就是放台风价的当天是8点
然后如果是下一天结算的话
那就是晚上8点到下一天的1点半
所以就是不到不到一天的时间就会结算了
但是如果下一天释放台风价的话
原本那天应该结算
但是如果台北释放台风价股票就不开市
所以就会延后一天结算
那时间价值就会大幅增加
然后选择权是过月久以后结算的选择权
价值会越高
就是例如说
如果你跟别人赌说台积电在300年之后
会不会涨过2000块
跟三天之后会不会涨过2000块
三天的话游戏规则好像不行
还是差不多刚好可以
反正就是这个机率会差很多嘛
就是例如说三个月后跟赌
一个礼拜之后
这个一定是差非常多的
所以就是月久以后
它的时间价值是会越高的
好
然后
因为台风价算是一种特殊的判例
特殊的判例就是
游戏制定规则的时候
为了一些平常不一定会很常遇到的特殊情况
制定了一些特殊的游戏规则
这就叫特殊判例
那各式各样的特殊判例
它很容易都会破坏掉了原本制定规则
想要达成的某些东西
例如说这个台风价它延后一天结算
那就破坏了就是可以预期固定的结算日
所以很好计算时间价值的这个效果
所以
就是在八点宣布放台风价的那个瞬间
选择权的时间价值
就会突然上升大约35%以上
所以
就是这个策略我们用手按就可以成功的原因是因为
至少到目前做这个策略的时候
大概券商就是造势商都需要30秒到1分钟之后
他才会把那个
他的钱全部都打进去
因为他们是需要把所有价格的选择权
都打高大概35%以上
所以他一次就要打超级巨量的钱进去
那我们可能只是打几百万进去
他们可能是用异尾单位
就是他们需要调整的造势金额打进去
所以他们应该是会有一些确认的流程
就是确定说
是不是真的有放台风价
因为毕竟就是很多假消息嘛
如果有一个人搞笑做了一个梗图
说放台风价
然后券商不知道
直接打进去所有的选择权价值
拉高40%
然后结果根本没放价
那券商可能一次直接赔好几亿
所以他们应该是有某一些确认的方式
然后那个确认的方式
会拉到30秒以上
那所以我们中间
就是人用手按30秒是一个很快的区间嘛
我们还是有很高的
就是很充裕的时间可以慢慢进场
好
反正如果他成功的时候
他就会成功获利40%左右
那这个就是很低风险高报酬
那当然他的风险我们也是无法衡量的嘛
就是如果台北市长宣布放台风价之后
然后你打进去了
结果台北市长又说不放台风价
那那个涨了40%就会跌回去
跌回原本价位
那你在中间到涨10%
20%的时候
其实都还可以继续买
结果跌回去了
那你就会有损失
不过就是到底要多久
要经过多久多久的人
才会遇到一次
就是有一个台北市长他发疯了
他居然宣布放台风价之后
又宣布不放台风价
光是宣布不放台风价
他就已经快要被骂死了
那如果他宣布放台风价之后
还宣布不放台风价
那他应该下一次选举都不用选了
应该没有人会偷给他
应该直接大家都气死
但是当然他这个没有违反物理定律
还是一个风险
还是有可能发生
不过这就是很低风险高报酬
好
然后我再讲一个就是
我希望先讲几个例子
让大家理解游戏漏洞是什么东西
就是我的YouTube有讲过一个
这个考试
就是在高中大学联考
也很常见的就是多选题
很general的任何多选题
都可以使用的最优猜答案的时候
有猜答案的数学策略
就是我的YouTube有讲两个
关于如果你题目不会写的时候
应该要怎么作答的两个主要战术
第一个是就是考试读心术
你用同理心去感受
如果老师出每个选项是
的时候他是在想什么
他内心是觉得这个答案是对的还是不对的
另外一个就是
就是纯数学的
第一个
考试读心术是心理学的
纯数学就是
多选题猜答案的最优数学策略
那因为我们在考试的时候
不可能每题都会写
如果你每题都会写
其实也不需要任何的战术
一定会有遇到不会写的题目
但如果不会写的题目
占30%好了
那这30%你可以拿到多少分数
其实差距会非常的大
如果那30%
两个人都不会30%的题目
结果你比他多拿了3%的分数
哇那这个学校就差好几个学校了
好那这个游戏漏洞就是
因为多选题有一个特别的规则
是不可以五个选项都是错的
因为五个选项都是错的话
他看起来就是空白
那这样就会导致根本就没有填的人
内提就会答对
那可能他们就是想要避免这样的事情
反正多选题是禁止五个选项都错
所以它就是一个游戏漏洞
因为如果你知道其中一两
例如说一个或两个选项是错的
其他选项你都不知道是对或错的话
那你就把剩下的选项全部都选
的话你会得到最高的期望值
然后我的影片里面有稍微
稍微经过一些表列式的计算
让大家不需要抽象思考
就可以知道这件事情是对的
不过如果是用抽象思考方式来想的话
就是数学的方式来想的话
就是因为五个选项都错的这个情况
是不会发生的
所以我们要尽量远离五个选项都错的这个情况
所以很容易就会得出
那你删掉一两个选项之后
剩下的选项全部都选的EV会最高
因为游戏规则
人为的删除了一种情况
那你要让被删除的情况
是你EV负最多的情况
就是你会被扣最多分的情况
那就是和你剩下的选项完全相反的情况
所以就是你把剩下的选项全部都选起来的话
会最高分
好那这段如果听不懂没有关系
因为这个是数学抽象思考
那反正这个影片也是有讲
就是把它列出来
然后证明说这样确实EV是最高的
好那我要讲的是说
就是游戏漏洞它不一定要是一个看起来很坏的事情
就是说什么
什么打篮球的时候
然后偷偷把别人的裤子脱掉之类的
就是不一定要是这种很坏的
虽然那样应该也是犯规的
好然后另外一个就是
我是一个非常理论派而且方法论的人
就是付出很小的努力
得到很大的回报是很简单的
只要你有使用正确的方法
就是方法正确的方法
还有做出比较好的选择
是比努力更重要的
就是公园可能有很多的老头
他们下了三四十年的旗
但是他们的旗力还是非常的弱
那就是AI它自己自我对战三十天五十天
它就直接成为所有人类都无法击败的存在
那当然人类跟人类比的学习也是
如果你用正确的方法的话
那你也是很容易下赢
下了几十年
但是都是在公园
就是根本没有在进步的人
好
那
就是
这边要讲的是
这是一个规律
就是特殊判例很容易造成游戏的漏洞
例如说
规定选择权不可以五个选项都没有
或者说
规定台风价的时候
其实算是会延后一天
那这些都算是特殊判例
那另外特殊判例就是
台股的限制涨跌幅是10%
那这个其实也是一个非常巨大的游戏漏洞
因为如果有一个就是
它有个几亿的额度
其实它就可以把其中一个股票给缩涨停
然后它缩涨停之后
就可以直接让别人全部都买不到
那就是在没有涨跌幅限制的情况下
显然就做不到这件事
它会无止境地把那股价无止境地拉高
但是在台股的话只有10%
它就可以很
就是完全不需要多付钱
或是多付非常非常少的钱
只要它有免费的委托额度
它就可以让别人完全买不到
然后它就可以用这个来进行一些很厉害的事情
那这个是在台股
目前都一直可以发生的事情
那当然这个漏洞需要
使用至少几亿的委托额度
所以小散户是用不了的
那至少就是中户大户以上几亿元的才可以做到
好
然后呢
这个我待会会讲一些在拉斯维加斯的
我今年做到了很多
蛮有趣的游戏漏洞的故事
那就是
可以当从
当然就希望非常有趣
然后而且可以从当中也可以学到很多新的概念
那例如说我发现在这个
这个
Paris赌场它的
超高额区
它在计算抽水的时候
它是
最小的那个抽水的指示物token是5元
那当然如果是在低额区的话
会有
会有一元或是更小的单位
但是
就是高额区它最小下注是1000
所以它就是最小的抽水它就是用5块
而且它是用非常漂亮的那个木头雕刻的那个token
那
所以它就很大气的
就是如果5块
就是不到5块的一半
尾数如果是2.5的话
例如说你要被抽水
52.5块的时候
那它就会只抽水50块
然后这个是没有写在游戏规则里面的
就是我自己
就是
其实只要下注几次
然后你有认真在看那个抽水是怎么抽的话
你就会发现
它是会舍去掉尾数的
那因为其实大部分去赌场的人
他们也没有那么在乎EV
因为百家乐就是一个很负EV的游戏
那如果一个在乎EV的人
百家乐最好车位就是
永远都不要玩百家乐
那如果他会在乎EV
他根本就不会走上桌嘛
所以
他定那个规则
他就没有特别去防止有人会很在乎EV
那但是因为
去玩那些游戏是会
有得到一些好处的
那这个我们后面会讲
那反正
这个
例子就是在讲说
如果他制定了一个特殊的
特殊的
特殊判例
特定的游戏规则的话
那每一次我们看到有
特殊的
特定游戏规则的时候
我们都可以思考
这个东西
会影响什么事情
他会破坏了原本
基础规则的什么东西
那他破坏的那个东西
会不会对整个游戏造成很大的影响
或者说
也不一定有很大的影响
就是足以让你变成有利可图
这样就可以了
那这个是一个很
general的思考方式
就是不一定是要是
特定这个游戏
各式各样的游戏
我们都很容易
用这种思考方式来
制定一个游戏漏洞的策略
好
那像这边
特殊判例
就是赌场的
少抽水
破坏了异地
然后
因为
就是讲
说什么
百家乐什么东西
就是
还是容易让大家觉得
观感很负面
所以还是要提醒一下
就是
我自己是绝对不会在
任何
就是也不推荐任何
大家在不合法的地方玩
然后
其中一个
就是不只是道德上的问题
是
如果你在
不合法的地方玩
任何的赌博游戏
不一定是百家乐
骰子
或者是任何的东西
你被作弊的机会都是
超级高
因为
在美国的拉斯维达斯赌场
他们是有第三方的反作弊的监管
就是
会有第三方的机构
去检查每一个赌场
他们有没有在作弊
那
那这样的话
基本上
他们就真的没有办法被作弊了
但是
在各种非法的
例如说
不管是线上
或者是现场
就是扑克牌的魔术
已经几乎是地球上
被研究的最透彻的魔术了
然后
如果是
我是说现场啊
现场发牌的那个人
他很容易就可以现场变魔术
而且
其实扑克牌的魔术
是非常好学的
就是
大学的魔术社
就可以把魔术做得超级好
更何况
那些人可能发几十年牌
他们都是超厉害的职业发牌手
那如果是线上的话
就更简单了
他就只是播一个影片给你看而已
就是
应该也有蛮多电影
就是在讲那种反诈骗的
就是
你基本上就只是
看了一个
不到一分钟的影片
然后你就付了他五十万
然后你就是
付了一个看影片的钱
然后你觉得你是输钱了
但其实没有
你只是在看影片而已
好
所以就是
就是
只在合法的赌场玩
不然很容易被作弊炸毒
然后再来就是
说
如果你是去
那种黑道的赌场玩
然后你利用了一些游戏漏洞
那
黑道是可以揍你一顿
或是直接不付你钱的
毕竟
就是
所有的游戏
其实
或者说所有的规则
所有的规则
都是建构在武力之上
就是如果
武力比较强的人
他是可以
自己乱定规则
或不遵守规则
那只是因为台湾
大家都没有办法拥有
有枪嘛
所以
大家都必须要很遵守法律
因为人民都没有枪
那
只有政府有枪
所以大家就要遵守
政府的法律
那在很多的
国家其实
如果很容易拥有枪的话
会有一些区域是
法律根本没有办法触及的地方
就是
因为所有的规则
其实都是建构在
强大的武力之上
那
如果我们是玩股票跟期货的话
就是在台湾就是非常安全的
因为政府有军队
然后人民没有
所以
这个股票期货就是一个
合法的赌场
而且非常安全
好
那我们继续讲
就是
就是我
其实一开始是去玩21点
然后玩21点
是实在是太容易被ban了
就是他们
因为那个游戏
游戏漏洞是公开的
就是我没有跟任何人学
那个21点的游戏漏洞
算牌要怎么做
我就是
直接问ChapGPT
然后叫ChapGPT
帮我上网查
帮我给我表格
然后
我就自己就可以学会了
就是这个应该是
就是
当然你要有一些查资料的能力
但是
这已经是超级公开的资讯了
所以
基本上
我很快就被附近的几家赌场都禁止完21点了
就是因为
就是被ban不是说一个超级厉害的事情
被ban其实非常的简单
就是
你就是鼠牌你就会被ban了
然后所以后来才
就是为了好玩
就是玩了这个高额的百家乐
然后
就是
就是玩了之后
就发现
其实还是有一些游戏漏洞
那因为
百家乐它一定就是一个负EV的游戏
所以
无论你怎么玩
基本上都是负EV的
但是
它会有游玩奖励
那它的
我去了凯撒集团
凯撒集团是
拉斯维加斯的两大最大的赌场集团的其中一个
所以
有非常非常多赌场都是使用这个规则
就是
你的游玩奖励回馈是
看你玩哪一种游戏
然后玩了多久
然后最大下注多少
最小下注多少
那它的那个
宣传的那个小册子上面就是这样写它的计算规则
那这个就会有一个很大的游戏漏洞
因为
它是用你玩了多久来估计你会输多少钱
也就是说
它是用你玩了多久来估计你玩了几把牌
然后
例如说它估计
我的下注的这个金额
例如说
是一千到一万
然后玩了三个小时
它就估计
那我应该会输三千美金
平均来说的话
那是一个小时玩四十把牌的情况
但是其实呢
我就是在那边一直磨蹭
一直拖时间
我一个小时只玩六把牌
那这样的话
我可能就可以
就是EV付的超级超级少
那可能它计算你平均
会在这个超高额区输三千块
所以你玩了这么久
它就会直接退一千块的给你
然后再让你得到免费的赤住
那这样的话你就会直接多赚嘛
例如说你的EV其实只付了三百块
然后它却给你一千块
然后你还可以得到免费的吃饭跟住宿
而且都是非常高级的吃饭跟非常高级的住宿
那这样的话就是赌场不能接受的情况
他们的游戏漏洞就被攻击了
好
然后因为
应该是几乎没有人攻击过他们的
或是很少有人攻击他们的百家乐这个游戏
因为去攻击这个游戏真的非常的奇怪
那反正我也就好玩
就是攻击了这个游戏
所以在玩了几天之后
他们后来就
应该其实也没有到几天
我玩了超过一个礼拜之后
他们才取消我的高额游玩奖励
就是
基本上就是以后不欢迎我去玩百家乐这样
然后
不过其实就是
各种游戏我们都是要
先制定出你的游戏的那个
目标是用什么单位来计量的
例如说
像在这个游戏里面
我自己制定的是拿到最多的EV
是用金钱来计量的
所以
我就得到了三个月赌场的免费高级套房
然后
还可以三个月免费的吃赌场的餐厅
但是呢
因为我又有点太在乎EV了
就是
我每天吃那个餐厅
因为是免费的嘛
我都吃超饱吃超撑
然后
我去年去的时候
就很多人在我照片下面留言说
马克扬去那边怎么变胖那么多
因为吃是免费的
我就会觉得
你就是要尽量吃EV才会拿到满
然后今年我又去
然后
今年我去比较久
去到三个月
然后我每天都吃到超撑
结果我回台湾
去照胃镜
发现胃食道逆流
就是
如果你的胃一直吃得很撑的话
胃里面的食物就会很容易倒流回食道
那就会有恶心想吐很不舒服的感觉
只要你一吃东西就会很不舒服
所以
就是
我反而因此
就是因为我有拿到免费的食物
反而胃食道逆流
但是呢
因为胃食道逆流
所以
我就变得很不能吃东西
就是我只要一吃东西
我就会超级想吐
所以
我从今年暑假Vegas回来之后
我就超级少吃东西
然后我就从80公斤
变到现在大概快要只剩70公斤
就是
减肥蛮多
然后本来肚子超大
然后现在肚子也变得平衡多
所以
就是
就是赛翁司马胭之飞斧
就是说
不小心
吃太多
然后胃食道逆流
结果反而还减肥了
这还蛮不错的
好
然后
我只是分享一下
这个游戏漏洞的思考方式
就是
亚洲的赌场
通常是没有这个漏洞的
因为
亚洲人就是比较会数学
然后比较会有那种很搞的情况
所以
那个
澳门
澳门几乎都是玩白家
然后美国几乎都是玩21点
澳门
或者是
菲律宾
柬埔寨
这些
就没有这个游戏漏洞
因为他们都是用
你下注了多少钱
来计算
你会拿到多少的反水
就是
这样的话其实是比较合理的
他
认为你一个小时会玩40把
那
如果是在澳门的话
我才会
有超多中国人
就坐在那边
然后完全不玩
就是
美国人比较少
会遇到
被亚洲人攻击
毕竟那边都是美国人
好
然后
而且
就是
因为
我们是同时有研究
心理学跟数学
所以
不只是
要使用
数学的战术
也要使用一些
心理学的战术
就是
如果
我是超级明显的
就是坐在那边
然后一直发呆的话
其实
很快赌场的经理
就会发现
我在干嘛
他会发现
我就是坐在那边
然后水奖励
那我可能很快
就会被BAN掉
所以呢
我自己想了一个
就是
我自己觉得非常巧妙的方法
叫做
好意收回下注
就是
百家乐的玩家
他们都很迷信一件事情
就是
那个叫看路
就是说
如果
他的那个
前几把开出来的答案是
红黑
那他们就觉得
下两把会再开红黑
因为前面都是
红黑
所以下一把就是红黑
当然
这个是完全没有任何
道理的嘛
你丢硬币
正反正反
不表示下两次是正反
不过
就是他们就是很信这件事情
那所以呢
就是
我会
就是下
跟那个看路相反的地方
例如说
前面是正反
红黑
那下一把
就
大家会下红嘛
那大家下注之前
我就先下黑
那
其他人就会下红
红黑
其实是装弦啦
那
反正我就下相反的地方
然后呢
其他的人只要一下注
我就
假装我是那种很有礼貌的日本人
啊
sorry sorry sorry
然后就把那个拿回来说
啊
就用英文抢说
我不喜欢跟别人下相反的注
啊
这样的话不好意思啊
然后其他人就会觉得我很有礼貌
这样子
那这样的话呢
我就会一直看起来
放了一万美金的下注上去
然后我有想要玩嘛
欸
结果别人放了
我又把一万美金拿回来
那这样看起来的话
就是
我一直下注一万美金
只是我后来把它拿回来了嘛
但是就是
我看起来就是一直下注
但是一直拿回来
那没办法
我就是这么客气
这么有礼貌
这个
这个没办法
我们亚洲人
有时候就是太客气了
其实那个美国人都会说
啊
没有关系啊
没有关系
大家玩得开心就好
啊
没有关系
我们真的很有礼貌
就这样
这个叫好意收回下注战术
那这个是一个非常厉害的战术
就是
用这个战术的话
你看起来
可能还是可以
一个小时有下30把
可是你可能连五把都没有下到
对
那这个就是一个非常厉害的战术
而且
赌场经理
其实
因为他们为而怕
就是让赌客觉得不舒服
不一定
有时候他们会站在桌旁边跟你聊天
但是
但是如果你表现是一个很内向的人的话
他就只会
这样
眼神有时候看一下
他看到你一直有在下注
这样他对你的印象也会比较好
然后再来就是
多付小费
塑造傻瓜毫克的形象
就是
基本上他们
其实还有一个衡量毫克的标准
就是你付了多少小费
然后还有一个是
你会不会一注下注到一万美金
那
因为我
会在manager
就是经理真的站在旁边的时候
真的下注一次
一万
让他记录到说
这个选项是有勾起来的
他是有发生这样的一次下注一万
一次下注一万
而且我还会一次给一百块的小费
但其实我只给一次
反正就是manager走过来的时候
我就会做那个加分项
他就做
这个人有这个加分项
有这个加分项
他就会觉得说
就是
会一次下注一万
再付EV的游戏
跟一次付一百块的小费
都是
傻瓜毫克才会做的事情
毕竟你给一百块的小费
他们相信
你给小费
核官会发给你更好的牌
但是那个是作弊的赌场才会
我们这个是不作弊的赌场
你发小费给核官
就是损失一百块而已
而且在拉斯维加市赌场
他们的核官
高额区
就都不是那种美女核官
通常都是老核官
因为老核官比较不会找错钱
然后还有另外一个
常见的游戏漏洞
就是核官会付错钱
因为其实
有时候会有一些新核官
他们是搞不清楚游戏规则
那可能有一个
选项
他是一个很少人下注的选项
然后他是
就是两对
反正就是某一件事情
然后他正确是一赔二十
然后我们真的有遇到有一个核官
他以为那个两对是一赔一百
然后所以
就是如果是那个核官在桌上的话
你就可以一直下注
排加尔的那个两对的side bet
那个本来是一个超级负EV的选项
但是因为他会赔你一百倍
所以他就变成一个超级正EV的选项
对
那这个
不过
我觉得这个
跟游戏漏洞还是有点不一样
就是我自己心里会觉得
这个
感觉是欺负人家搞不清楚状况
而且他搞不好以后会被骂
所以其实
我最后离开之前最后一天
我还跑去跟ban我的manager讲说
那个核官他会算错这个
要跟他讲一下
反正我要走了
而且他就是
对
我就觉得说这样还是不太好
我还是希望
就是在玩游戏的里面
大家每个玩家都还是
就是比较知道自己在做什么
然后大家有一些游戏的互动
然后可能我想了一个巧妙的策略
然后怎样子
我自己会觉得这样的游戏比较好玩
当然这个只是我想象中的世界
这个世界是永远不会达到那个情况的
好
然后
另外一个有趣的心理学战术
就是假装喝酒
就是
你知道在台湾
那个酒店妹
他会有那个
另外旁边弄一个水杯
就是他喝了酒之后
他会再喝一口水
但是他喝水的时候
水杯里面水会变多
因为他把酒给吐回去
我觉得这个蛮厉害的
所以在那个
拉斯维加斯的时候
如果你在下注的时候
你有一直不停的点免费的酒
一直喝的话
你的评价也会比较高
所以我就一直点酒
然后喝
然后再把它吐回水瓶里面
这个也是一个非常厉害的战术
这是跟酒店妹学到的战术
假装喝酒
他就看起来
就是
因为我一开始有去一家赌场
然后我就演我喝很醉
但是后来我的朋友就跟我说
你这样演会有一个很大的问题
因为赌场里面都是
全部都是有摄影机的
所以赌场就会看到
我从房间走出来
然后走去坐电梯
然后快要走到那个赌博厅的时候
突然开始很醉
他在看那个录影就觉得
这个演员怎么演的
这个故事线这么奇怪
他就没有喝酒
他突然走过去
就开始很醉
然后很快就会被ban掉
因为你就是表示你
你是在故意在做奇怪的事情
好
然后还有
这个多参加换newshoot的时间
就是
如果一条牌换
结束之后
他们要经过一些很复杂
也没有很复杂
反正就是需要
5分钟以上的时间
可能快要10分钟的时间
他才能把
就是一条很长的牌
重新打开
然后经过一些清点或什么东西
那因为我们是要水时间嘛
所以
只要
快要
换一个newshoot的时候
我就会赶快换坐到那个地方
然后坐在里面等他换newshoot
do
那这样我就不需要
特别想什么奇怪的事情来做
因为
因为我很合理啊
我就是在等他换newshoot
那没办法
我就是喜欢玩newshoot
嘛
好
其实还很多啦
就是
我尽量会在各式各样的那个
就是去了解那个游戏规则
然后尽量做到各式各样的细节
我们把每个细节都最好
做好
然后去
就是把游戏给玩好
这样子
好
然后
其实
赌场被优势玩家攻击之后
他们就会修改规则
例如说
我大概玩了一个礼拜的那个超高额百家儿之后
他们就
那个
改了规则
因为
就是那个manager
发现我如果有下注
常常下注1050
其实超级奇怪
一开始我是说
这个是一个我们的亚洲迷信
就是我觉得
一个黄色上面放两个绿色
这样会给我带来幸运
但是因为我做太多次了
其实他们应该
还是会经过一些
因为那个manager也是一个
也是一个
会算牌的
所以
他也是一个很聪明的人嘛
他至少他一定也是一个数学家
他很快就发现说
原来你是要故意少被抽水2.5块
然后他就跟那个
核官就是定义新一个规定
就是说
虽然5块钱以下是没有token
可以放在旁边记录的
但是你们要自己记在脑袋里面
然后如果累积到5块的时候
你就要放一个5块的token上去
去抽他水5块钱
那但是因为
就是
他用token就是为了
避免很难记嘛
因为
抽水可以会有1.25块啊
然后
3.75块
1.75块
所以
就是
我为了对抗他这件事情呢
我就
不下注
1,050
我就下注
1,035
1,045
1,065
那这样的话
他要把1,035
乘以0.05
的数字记得起来
然后下一次再跟
另外一个奇怪的
可能2,135
乘以0.05
的尾数记线
他就会
因为正常人
一定会记不起来
因为他不是只在做这件事
他还有在发牌
他还有需要处理很多其他的事情
所以
他根本就记不清楚
然后他后来就会放弃这件事情
然后
当然因为
就是这样很明显
我攻击他们就非常明显
所以过几天之后
他们就不给我玩那个游戏了
好
所以这就是
赌场霸王条款
就是
毕竟
只要是游戏
就会有漏洞
然后就会被攻击
那毕竟
这个游戏是
你攻击的是庄家
那庄家就可以不给你玩
那在股市
股票市场的话
就不是这样
就是
股票市场
和期货
和选择权市场
你攻击的是其他玩家
而且
其他玩家根本不会知道
自己是被谁攻击的
因为
就是
你永远不会知道
你的成交对手是谁
除非你们都是超级大户
所以
在
股票期货选择权市场
就是用各种的游戏漏洞
去攻击这个市场
是非常好的
因为
就是
政府不可能会说
你怎么巧妙的使用了
这个台风架这件事情
以后不给你下单选择权了
不可能这样吗
就是
我们大家去
一直下单
那政府每天都可以抽
10亿以上的水钱
他们其实庄稼也是抽水
那你下单越多
当然是越好
好
然后
就是
基本上
我会更general的定义
赌博
就是
文赌跟无赌
那
像是
说
结婚啊
考大学啊
这些都是属于文赌
就是很有技术的赌博
那如果你选到了一个好老公好老婆的话
这个
你这辈子就会过得比较开心快乐很多嘛
所以
结婚是属于文的赌博
那这个是有技术靠理论知识的
那
比如说
投胎啊
丢骰子啊
这些就是
五赌
拼的是命跟运
但是呢
就是
在一些特别的情况下
例如说
我们这个
例子
我们就可以把百家乐从无赌完成文赌
就基本上
其实只要是有
固定的游戏规则的游戏
你大部分都还是可以去找一些游戏规则的漏洞
特别去攻击它
那当然
这个是因为百家乐大概只有
负1%到负1.2%的EV啦
如果是像
台湾的大乐透或运动彩卷
那种
EV负30%以上
甚至EV负到50%的
那个
那个就是你去攻击它也没有任何用处
就是如果你买
政府的大乐透或公益彩卷
你就知道你真的是在做公益
那个EV是负超多
真的负到懒
如果你要赌博的话
然后你想要完全贫运性
不知道自己在干嘛的话
你就随便买一个选择权
可能都比较好
毕竟选择权是一个超级公平的游戏
好
然后呢
就是
我已经连续每年都去拉斯维加斯很多年了
然后
我基本上
WSOP就是
六月七月的时候都会去
然后我觉得
就是基本上
虽然我被ban了嘛
但是
那些技术都是
其实很公开而且很容易学会
就是当然是需要花时间练习啦
那个
21点的那个表格
其实就像是一个99乘法表的表格一样
那99乘法表其实是一个很难的表格
因为
其实基本上它就是隐备嘛
你如果
就是没有任何方式可以理解
为什么37是21
然后为什么2乘3是6
2乘3是6
就是一个规定
那
那个
21点它基本上是一个比较大张的99乘法表
然后你把那个表格上面全部的格子都记起来
的话
你就可以
就是
就是会赢走赌场很多的钱
这个真的非常简单
然后
就是
但是因为美国人数学真的实在是太烂了
所以我去那边玩了三个月
我总共只遇到了五个
就是
有在算牌
而且正确执行的人
然后
而且都是亚洲人
没有任何一个是美国人
所以
他们其实
美国
最多桌数的游戏
就是桌子数最多的
还是Blackjack
21点
那
他们其实还是很安全
会赚非常多的钱
因为
大部分人都不会数学
然后
21点它
那个游戏大概就有点像是
它每一次都会考你99乘法表的一个格子
然后你就会答21
然后你就会赢到一点点钱
然后52
然后就会答10
但你不是百分之百赢钱啦
你会
获得一个
赢钱的机会
这样子
好
那
如果
顺利的话
今年12月我也会希望可以再去一次
然后
如果
反正有兴趣的话
可以密我的
那个粉钻
这样
好
然后
其实就是
在现在啊
各式各样的东西的练习都变得简单很多
就是
啊
一万小时定律
他说的其实是
在特定一个时代
然后你要成为一个顶尖的小停情家
然后你在某一个年纪之前要练习一万个小时
但是
大部分的事情都没有到那么困难
例如说
我待会会展示的超强技术或者是21点
这些大概都是可能300个小时到500个小时就可以学会的事情
那这个已经算非常简单了
300个小时
如果你一天练习三个小时
一百天
你大概三个月就可以学会这件事了
当然
有的人会觉得
花一百天每天练三个小时还是很久
但是
你这样就可以成为某个领域非常非常厉害的人
那这个已经是非常非常棒的嘛
好
然后我们这个稍微穿插的
讲一点跟股票期货有关
一点跟股票期货没关的事情
然后
我尽量每年都办
三次左右的这个群艺期货讲座
然后所以
每次我讲的都还是
有一定的就是记录我这几个月做的事情的成分
然后所以有些可能会是你们知道我讲过的事情
但是这个影片都还是会放在那个
就是
现在好像不能放在网络上
但反正我都会把它记录下来
然后
好
就是
今年大家都知道嘛
4月7号有一天
台子旗的日盘是一架所跌停的
然后
但是呢
就是
因为跌停是有涨跌幅限制的嘛
那所以
它就被卡在就是
就是-10%的地方
然后没有办法继续跌下去
那但是
选择权的话
你是可以从
原价位
或者是各种价位选择权
只要那个选择权没有
触及到涨停或跌停的话
你就可以看出来
当天实际的跌幅
就是
在大致上对称的地方
然后经过一些数学计算
最简单的看法就是
看起来对称的那个数字
会是
现在
这个
就是
台子的真实数字
那大概会是在
跌17%附近的地方
也就是说
它只反映出了10%的跌幅
但其实
当天可能会在
跌13%到
跌19%附近这样跳来跳去
在开盘的时候
是跌超级多
很接近跌到快两根跌停这样
好
然后
就是可以知道
当天的跌幅是远远超过10%的
但是因为股票现货有10%跌幅限制
反映不出完整的跌幅
所以
就是当天有很多的财经网红
他们是搞不清楚游戏规则
他们就会觉得说
当天的股票是便宜了10%
那就是打9折
然后就鼓吹粉丝当天日盘一起进场买现货
然后他们就贴当天他们买现货的对账蛋
那当然这个就是一个非常不好的动作
就是他们其实是买的比较贵了
然后
但是他们以为买的比较便宜了
那这个就是不了解游戏规则会发生的事情
好
然后
就是
因为
虽然当时我是有特别嘲笑特定一个人
但是我跟他也没有什么仇
所以就是我没有打算在会被记录的影片上
让大家知道他是谁
那
就是
但是有一个很有趣的事情就是
那个被我嘲笑的人
他每天都写文
嘲笑不败教主
然后其实我以前也有写
發文嘲笑过不败教主
但是因为那个人嘲笑不败教主的频率实在太高了
然后我又
我又发文把那个人修理得很惨
然后所以不败教主就觉得我是他的盟友
他后来就都会帮我按赞
都会帮我留言这样子
但是其实
我以前是有发文嘲笑过不败教主
就是
这个是
这个是国际局势就是这样子
就是
敌人的敌人就是朋友
虽然你有嘲笑过我
但你嘲笑了我讨厌的人
那你就是我的盟友
好
然后
这个
好
就是
当天的
因为其实
在那种暴跌的时候
是
有可能可以观察一些东西
然后可以去抓一些转折的机会
那实际上当天我就在夜盘的时候
就是
在
台积电期货第二天
第二根碟亭打开的时候
去
在夜盘买了台积电期货
等于是说
我跟日盘去买台积电现货的人
相比
我在同一天
买到比他们便宜10%的价格
那这个就是差超级多嘛
那当然
他们可能很多
有的人会抬杠说
反正过了100年之后
台积电有涨回来就好
但是
毕竟我们玩这个游戏就是
尽量要赚到越多钱越好嘛
然后这个也不是说什么
你差了20块的手续费
或什么之类的
这个是
直接一进场就亏5%
然后
如果你在
使用一些数学技术的话
你可以直接
跟别人同一天
交易到差10%的东西
那
这个就是差距非常非常的大
所以
就是了解游戏规则
然后
知道这个游戏怎么玩的话
你可以得到的效果
还是会比别人好超级多
因为毕竟
就是股票期货
他对普通人来说
就是一个
纯数学猜数字的游戏
那当然
川普他可以是一个
我出数字给大家猜的游戏
然后他的儿子可能
就会先知道
爸爸今天出的数字是多少
那
大部分人应该是没有办法
用这种方式玩这些游戏
所以我们就是学习
这个一些数学的知识
还是蛮有用的
好
然后
这个是一些
还是记录一下一些感触
那
就是
被我嘲笑的人
他就会一直
他就会不承认错误嘛
然后
我也没有特别
要针对特定一个人
就是
会有一大类的人
他们都是
会不想要承认错误的
那当然可能会有商业的考量
但是
基本上
在我那个
就是
如何在各个领域
快速成为大师的
那个
课程体系里面
有六个
就是
主要的方法
让你可以在各个领域
快速的成为大师
其中一个就是
你做任何事情
你都要
复盘检讨
然后
就是
检讨自己有什么
做得更好的地方
那当然
他有一个前提
你要先处理好自己的情绪
然后
复盘检讨
例如说
你考试考不好
那你可能可以先
在心里咒骂老师
怎么题目出得太难
我这么厉害的同学
这个居然
都考个30分
那但是你在骂完老师之后
你还是要
检讨就是
这一次的学习过程
有什么样做得不好的地方
可能
我们可以就是
就是做得更好
这样
那这个其实是蛮困难的
尤其是
如果这件事情
越会
危及到
一个人
对于自我价值的认同
例如说
像是分手
如果你跟一个人分手了
然后你还能够自我检讨说
是不是我对他有什么
不够好的地方
然后我
是不是
对他不够温柔
还是怎样的话
那这个是非常困难
因为大部分人
分手都是
跟别人描述
都是说
因为他对我太凶了
因为他根本就没有考虑我
因为他不体贴
因为如果你检讨自己
就会
触发内心的一个机制
觉得说
是不是别人
觉得我不够好
所以才跟我分手
那这个会危及自己的
自我认同
好好像讲了太多
跟数学没有关系
我们还是尽量
focus在一些
一些正经的数学上
好
然后再来就是
就是因为
因为人被嘲笑
他就会想要反击
然后他后来就
被嘲笑
他就发文说
因为他一开始是说
就是
根本就不可能
我们小散户就可以交易到
就是
赚钱的那些
很容易赚钱的机会
然后我就写
写了
我其实以前就写过
台风价策略
就是说
其实
短线交易
可以赚钱
还是非常简单
你只要熟悉游戏
规则什么的
然后呢
后来他有发一篇文说
就是
股市是一个
如果你赚的钱多了
别人赚了
就是别人赚了更多的钱
就會排挤到你赚了钱
你自己赚的钱
就会变少了
所以不会有人
写予分享好的策略给别人
那因为
就是
这样的话会有损于他自己
那其实这个是
亚洲的
就是比较老的
人有可能会有的想法
我相信他
不只是为了抬杠
他应该是
内心是真的这样想的
就是
我在
以前
我有一个朋友
他后来去读私立学校
然后
那个学校里面的人
他们
他们都是
如果你自己得到一份很好的
考古题
或模拟考题
或学习讲义
他们是不会分享给同学的
因为他们觉得
如果你把讲义分享给同学
那他在班上的名次
就会提升
你在班上的名次
就会下降
当然这是真的
但是
我很幸运的是
我从小到大
我刚好都是
因为是考试的
我是读
永和数理自由班
然后建宗的数理自由班
然后
后来是去读医学系
所以
都是跟
比较单纯淳朴的
就是很数学的那种
宅男
当同学
大家都是
非常愿意教别人的
所以
我都一直很幸运的
在一个
很正面的社群
Community
里面
就是
跟别人一起
互相进步
那
所以
我在国中
跟高中的时候
没有补习
但是
我的效果
会比补习更好
因为
我跟我的同学
遇到各种东西
如果不会的话
都会互相讨论
互相学习
那
基本上
这个效果
会比上补习班还好
因为
例如说
你跟同学
在一起研究
传说对决的话
你可能就会
真的很认真研究
但是如果你们是一起
在研究功课的话
那你们就会在功课这个游戏上玩得很好
所以就是
这个是一个
我觉得
其实我一直不停地进步很快
一个很重要的东西
就是
我会
愿意分享我的秘诀给别人
那这跟中国的古代的时代
已经不一样
中国很多的江湖郎中
他们行走江湖
他最有价值的就是那个
就是可能
祖传秘方
对
就是好几倍之前传下来的那个秘诀
那如果他那个秘诀被知道
他行走江湖的秘密就全部都没有
他就失去自己的价值
但是在我们现在这个时代
不是这样
就是我们的资讯流通
已经超级快速超级发达
你很快就可以学会
非常非常多的事情
所以
如果你很愿意分享
你的各种秘诀给你周边的人
他就会跟你形成连结
他可能会
就会变成你的盟友
然后以后他有很好的东西
他也会分享给你
所以就是
我以前在玩炉石的时候
我常常会打到亚服天梯第一
但是我都会做那个超牌大拳
让大家去抄我的那个牌组是怎么做的
那有
就是
因为那个没有赌钱
大家就不会觉得说
如果别人这样抄了你的牌
他不是就有可能打赢你
然后你就不是天梯第一
你就会排名掉下来吗
那当然这个是
这个是很有可能会发生的
但是如果我遇到有人用跟我完全一样的牌
还打赢我的话
其实我会觉得很高兴
因为表示他是我的盟友的一份子
然后我们会一起进步一起学习
这样
所以就是
当然
因为现在加入了这个群艺期货的投顾部门
所以我现在就不能在这个
免费的YouTube频道或者是免费的演讲
去讲付费课程等级的策略
那这个是
就是有一些公司会有他的商业考量
但这个是非常合理的
就是也都是可以理解的
那所以我今天讲
比较少股票期货的明确的策略
但是希望还是可以让大家感受到
就是如果跟我玩各式各样的游戏的话
那都是就是非常的好玩
当然也是会
也是战术也都是会非常的成功
然后另外一个是会非常的好玩
然后讲了一小段跟这个股票期货
我们再讲一下其他的金钱游戏
就是21点的算牌输牌
那它是一个非常有趣的事情
就是以前的21点它是只有用一副牌的
然后如果只有一副牌的话
那个被数学家攻击
数学家去玩那个游戏
这一副牌尸戏
应该赌场很快就会输到
就是非常非常惨
那所以现在就是改规则变成
使用更多副牌
那这样你已经出现哪些牌的影响就会更小
然后最后剩下一副多的时候
它就会直接洗牌
那因为如果你玩到可以玩到最后一张的话
那当然是不行
如果你把前面的牌都记起来的话
那玩到最后几张的时候
你不是都已经直接知道剩下的是什么牌
你已经知道剩下的就是3、5、2、7
那这样的话那个游戏
最后一个突然下注一个超大注
那赌场一定受不了
所以现在有微微的修改了一些游戏规则
但是还是不足以逆转
就是玩家可以对赌场正EV这件事情
然后反正属牌的基本原理就是
如果你记得已经发出了什么牌的话
那剩下来的牌的组成就会不一样
例如说如果有一个选项是赌下一张随机的牌
是不是JQK10点的话
那你已经记得出过几张JQK
你就会知道JQK在剩下的牌里面的比例的变化
所以一个-EV的选项
可能在一些情况就会变成正EV
而且那些情况还是很容易发生的
因为就是你前面连续发出几张JQK10
或者是其他牌的话
这个都是很容易发生的事情
然后再来我们讲一个就是另一个游戏
就是因为我们现在也是规定不能够展示对账单
那我们还是要展示一些有趣的事情
让大家觉得说
哇这个世界真的是非常的有趣和奇妙
而且其实大家应该可能都是会参加很多期货演讲座的人
所以我们让大家看一个不一样的表演也是蛮有趣的
那我先介绍一下超强记忆书
它看起来是怎样
就是电视上常常会有那种超强记忆书
就是例如说随机的让观众下面的观众讲100个数字
然后过了几秒钟之后
那个人就把100个数字全部都记起来了
那当然很多人会觉得那个可能是串通好的
当然有很低的机率是串通好的
因为这个不需要串通
这个超强记忆书的表演比较像是投三分球
然后这个世界上没有投篮这个游戏
然后它练习了投三分球
那大家就会觉得说
哇好扯喔
这么远居然可以精准的投进篮框
所以它是一个可以练习的东西
然后它主要其实就只能用来表演
因为你在就是现代
已经不需要自己主动的记住100个数字
或记住一张超大的表格
我们就可以把它记录在手机上
或是直接上网插就可以
就是这个跟古代不一样
古时候的读书人
他们最厉害的事情是
把很多的书记在脑袋里面
那因为以前他们是用竹简写书嘛
就是你拥有一本书
那个都贵到不行
但是现在我们已经不需要了
就是你记得超多东西已经不厉害了
主要就是你有更强的抽象
思考能力
那个会比较厉害
所以超强技术主要就是用来表演
然后也可以用来考试
然后其实在其他地方用处真的很小
而且它是一个需要主动去发动的技能
就是你需要用一个特殊的方式去思考
然后才可以记得那些东西
就是就算是我
我很常停车都忘记我停在哪里
因为我没有特别去记那个地上的号码
那超强技术不是说
你停完车然后就走掉
然后你根本没有记地上你是停在哪一个号码
你就会知道在哪一个号码
因为你就忘记看了嘛
那这样的话还是会忘记
所以它其实就是一个用来表演的东西
我只是先解释一下
就是这件事情看起来很神奇
但是随着科学家对于脑科学的研究
所以我们越来越了解记忆是怎么形成的
我们科学家就制定了非常明确的一套办法来达成
接下来我们会看到那个效果
那我这个影片是我跟两个就是学生
然后就在他家
然后我就说我表演给你们看
然后他们可以在就是白板上随便他们写下
在一个5x5的格子里面随便写下任何的词语
然后也可以写数字
然后也可以写英文
那当然要是我会的语言
所以我规定他们只能写
英文、中文跟数字
这三种类型
那当然如果他写阿拉伯文
或者什么古希伯来文
这个我当然没有办法记起来
我根本不知道那是什么东西
好
那就是我跟他们讲这个规则
然后这两个小朋友就在白板上写了
25个字
好我们一起来看一下这个影片
你觉得我
哇塞
这个算很大
连中文字也有一个超长的
你觉得有这么长的
大家就要
不然我们不用陪伴阿拉伯文
你觉得它差不多有接起来
都这样
5分钟了
5分钟
这么久
大概要这么久
那我就看了一眼
然后我就全部记起来
我就看了一眼
因为我逼得你
因为不然我看了一眼
才会知道
那我拿上
好
OK
反正我就看了
这个模式
欸
可是那个
就是啊
放你看到
哦
这样我们一看不到
好
一行
小狗瓦斯
啊
你记完了
是不是记下来
哦
蛤
你记完了啊
哦
我刚才问女人
随便问了
我已经记完了
哦
你记完了啊
你记完了
哦
嗯
好
小狗瓦斯
iPhone
WiFi
好
可以啊
第三
第三行
第三行是
电脑
啊
第二行
第二行是
Messenger
Invertical
港
床
冷气
哇
很累
最后一行
最后一行是
三二九
一二九
然后下一个是
六七一一一一零二七二三一
哈哈哈哈
哈哈
黃花蛋
出人的哈喽
然后
哇塞
一字行
一字行是
一字行每一堆数字都在哪
不是说他都在词吗
一字行是
藍宝石
然後
欸我都是数字啊
哇塞
D6
沒有D6
哇塞
好
就到這邊
就是
其實這個也可以
可以弄一個課程
教大家
但是應該是
給小朋友
基本上
他只能用來考試
然後
其實真的
對於
對於成年人來說
真的沒什麼用
就是除了表演給別人看之外
我想不到任何場景
你會需要突然記得一個很大張的表格
真的不知道可以幹嘛
真的沒什麼用
但是他就是表演用的
然後在一開始
科學家
剛開始
發明了這一套方法之後
有一個魔術師就在魔術大會上表演這個魔術
就是
他就是讓
就是丟飛盤
然後讓底下的魔術師
每一個人就
講一個詞語
然後他在丟飛盤
丟給下一個人
然後再講一個詞語
然後他就記得了50個詞語
然後把他講給大家聽
然後
現場的魔術師就覺得
看好神奇喔
他是怎麼控制那個飛盤
全部都丟到他的暗裝的
這個
就是
好
反正就是一個
也是一個遊戲
一個蠻有趣的表演
然後
只是我要講一個
有趣的事情
就是
在智力測驗裡面
在現在標準的智力測驗
智力測驗是不能先讓大家知道
會測什麼的
所以我就是很空泛的講
其中有一個項目
跟測技術很有關係
然後跟我剛剛那個影片的形式有一點點像
反正他就是要測技術
而且他是要你倒著講
就是你先講第25個
然後再講第24個
這樣他會改變你的順序這樣
然後
因為
就是我在大學的時候
很喜歡一個心理師
然後
我就想逗他
他有一次他在學
那個
就是
自力測驗的
然後
他就要說要給我練習
但是因為我是醫生
所以
我可以賴皮
就是
我可以先去病房看那個
題本是什麼
所以我就先知道全部的題目
跟全部的答案
然後
所以在那個
選項的題目
我就會直接知道
其實那不是選選項
那是很困難的開放式題目
例如說什麼
日本是在哪一年建國的
什麼第五個
第三個被刺殺的總統是誰
就是那根本不可能有人知道的事情
那我就會全部都知道
然後
其中一個項目是
測你的記憶
然後
一大堆
超長的東西
然後你要把它倒著背出來
然後無論他加到多長
他加到
我後來就跟他說
因為正常的人的記憶的長度
大概會是在12個單位左右
所以10碼的電話號碼
我們是可以記起來的
而且你是
可以聽完一個10碼電話號碼之後
把它倒著念過來
我們正常的working memory
是這樣的大小
但是呢
我就直接跟他說
你就講100個
然後我就把它倒著念回去
然後就直接測不出智力的上限
就是
我只是要
對
但其實也不能證明什麼
因為
這個也不是遊戲漏洞
這就是犯規嘛
因為我已經先知道要測什麼題目
有點像是那種
偷偷知道考試的答案
題目是什麼這樣
好
反正這個是一個
很有趣的事情
好
然後再來是
就是股市有很多
低風險高報酬的事件交易機會
那像
除了我們之前說的
台風價其實算是一個
比較相對比較少發生的
所以我一直覺得
我公開講出來
還沒有到很有關係
因為畢竟
它
一年能夠發生的次數真的很少
就是讓大家知道也沒關係
但是有很多的事件交易
它們其實是很常發生的
例如說
最重要的公司
其實地球上很重要的公司
非常非常多
他們的財報公佈
他們的法說會
他們的經
然後或者是美國的經濟數據公佈
基本上
地球上只有美國的經濟數據公佈
是比較重要的
就算我們在台灣
台灣的經濟數據公佈
都不太影響台股
因為美國的
美股會聯動影響整個地球
然後或者是
國家元首之間的會面
然後
還有那個
美聯儲FED主席的講話
那個是一個
就是這種的話
就是一種
英文聽力測驗
就是你現場
馬上聽他們在講什麼
然後
然後他們講了什麼話
可能就會暴漲或暴跌
然後甚至什麼
他們打招呼的方式
是用什麼
什麼大家好
還是早上好
這個大家都有歸納出一個
上漲漲跌的機率
這樣子
好
反正就是
有很多
股市有非常多的
事件交易的機會
好
然後還有巨大的公司
互相的投資
像現在這個時代
就是
他們那個叫做
AI公司之間的循環經濟
就是
A公司投資
B公司100億
然後
B公司再去投資
C公司100億
然後
這樣的話
每家公司的價值都大幅增加了100億
然後每一次
就是
A公司投資
比如說
NVIDIA投資
OpenAI的時候
兩個股價都一起暴增
然後
OpenAI再投資
A&D
兩個公司股價一起暴增
反正就是
有很多很多的事件
然後還有一些重大政策的公布
當然也包括我們說的
川普的各式各樣的關稅
然後當然還有一些其他的
例如說
其實地球上
還是蠻容易爆發一些小幅度的區域戰爭的
其實幾乎正常來說
一兩年地球上就是會有幾個比較大的戰爭
這個
還是算是
當然是一個很悲慘的事情
但是
就是人類之間當然還是要有武力衝突
所以
這些都是
就是
都是很好的
低風險高報酬的事件交易機會
然後
基本上我就是
就是很擅長
找到各種各樣的遊戲方法
然後所以
就是會
在各式各樣的事情上面
就會有各式各樣的事件交易的機會
這樣子
好
那因為現在不能夠就是明確的講太多
很具體的東西
但是
我基本上就是跟大家講
就是跟我一起玩遊戲會非常好玩
然後會
我覺得應該是可以感受到
巧妙
就是它不只是你很無聊在賺錢
就是
不只是說
什麼看這個線
看起來是1、2、3波
然後A、B波
然後這邊有個翻轉
所以我們就進場
這個感覺就超級無聊的
我希望
這個大家今天聽完有覺得說
來
如果跟我一起學玩遊戲的話
是有趣到不行
當然
這個是限定一些特定的人
才會覺得有趣到不行
但是我會來聽這個演講的人
應該滿多人會覺得非常有趣
通常會是離主然後的那種理工宅男之類
類似這樣的角色
我發現今天其實滿多女生來的
滿驚訝的
因為我的YouTube
那個看後台
都是超過90%以上是男生觀看
那今天看起來有超過10%的是女生
所以我覺得
非常的厲害
當然今天有
哇
二樓也坐滿啦
兩百多個人
看起來
看起來真的是滿多人來
還不錯
謝謝大家來這樣
好
然後我們繼續講
就是
呃
我們不只是因為我們是群益期貨
所以我們才
才希望大家交易期貨
而是交易期貨
確實比交易股票
會賺更多
而且賠更少
而且是
就是
幾乎
待會我會解釋
幾乎全部的情況
都是交易股票
會比交易現貨更好
那主要的原因就是因為
他們的交易成本
實在是差太多了
就是
股票的交易成本
一定會超過0.3%
因為是
交易稅
再加上手續費
然後手續費
你不一定會得到多少幾折
但是至少一定超過0.3%
然後正常人
應該會到0.34%左右
或0.33%以上
那
那個
股票
跟
期貨相比
期貨的交易成本就
超級低
就是
通常
我這邊是寫
低於1/2000
那如果
台子期的話
就
再更低
就是
如果是個股期的話
可能會在1/2000左右
然後如果是
指數期貨的話
可能會在1/10000以下
當然我說的是
不包括為買為賣的價差
但其實
就算
包括進為買為賣的價差
就是
期貨還是
幾乎全部的情況都遠遠的比現貨
股票更好
所以就算是存股
或是存台股
或是存
美股的大盤
也是存指數期貨
會遠遠的優於存現股
就是
它唯一的限制就是
你沒有辦法每個月只存幾千塊
當然
但是數學上來說的話
它絕對是比較好的
因為
就是
如果你是在
完全一樣的
價錢
進場
任何的股票
或者是指數期貨
然後再一樣的價錢賣掉的話
那
就是等於是
你賺的那個錢
要扣掉一個交易成本
然後這個交易成本
就會差到
超級多
例如說
如果是
台積電是
150萬的話
然後乘以
0.32%
這個就是
4500塊左右
也就是說
你交易
來回交易
台積電的
現貨
你就要花好幾千塊的交易成本
那
如果你是交易期貨的話
那就是一個
低到你幾乎
完全可以忽略的交易成本
那就是差超級多
然後
那當然還是講一下限制
就是
如果你是要存
存股
然後你是存一口為台
一口為台
價值也有28萬
所以
對於小資主來說
如果他只想要
每個月存三千塊的話
那還是
買零股就可以了
所以
就是
我只是講說
交易期貨一定會比
交易現貨更好
但是如果你是非常小資主的話
其實就是
你要存錢就是
存個
什麼
0050啊
或是
S&P500啊
或是什麼
VT啊
QQQ啊
這些都是
存大盤
或是分散全球
這些都是很好的選擇
當然
相對於期貨
你會多付幾百塊的手續費
其實也就沒什麼差
畢竟
對小資來說
就是你只存幾千塊
那個也不是你主要翻身的方式
好
然後我們講一些交易股票的現貨
會比交易期貨更好的特殊例外情況
第一個就是
超級大呼
需要自己影響股價
那他就會同時買期貨跟現貨
因為
如果他的部位大到他打進去
他會直接讓
期貨的價格
大幅的上升
或者是大幅的下降的話
那他當然要同時的買現貨
期貨跟現貨
例如說都要打掉一個Tick
那他們就是
一起打掉一個Tick
那他就要同時買
那這種情況才會買現貨
但是
大部分的人應該都沒有這個問題
然後再來是
需要巧妙利用特殊的遊戲規則
只好交易現貨
例如說我在很多年前
有分享過一個巧妙的
處置股的策略
那當然現在
我都要隱藏那些影片了
現在已經看不到了
不過就是
有一些特殊的遊戲規則裡面
你會不得不交易現貨
因為你想要利用一些特殊的遊戲規則
那像是
處置股就是
他明顯就會造成很大的遊戲漏洞
因為他就是有很多很多特別的限制這樣
好
然後
再來是
太小型的股票
他會沒有股票期貨
然後或者是
股票期貨的流動性太低
也不一定要股票期貨
也可以是電子期貨
或者什麼期貨的流動性太低
那
那他的微賣
流動性很低的話
微賣微賣價差
通常就會表示他微賣微賣價差很大
那你想要買跟賣
本身你就需要去
強迫跟對手成交
那微賣微賣價差太大的話
交易成本的損失就會超過現貨的交易成本
好
不過這些都是
特殊的情況
因為大部分的股期
其實流動性應該都還不錯
當然也有比較差的
但是
那就是去只交易熱門的股票
畢竟其實我們要
如果要做一些短線交易的話
通常都是去交易當下最熱門
就是你直接點開成交值排行榜
前幾名的那幾檔個股
那他們的股票期貨
基本上流動性也都是超級好
成交量超級大
所以就是基本上
全部的情況
就是除非你真的很大戶
不然的話
都是交易期貨比交易現貨更好
然後就是
反正
期貨的開戶也是免費的嘛
就是
基本上可以去了解一下
期貨的這些遊戲規則會不錯
好
然後再來是
很多人以為
期貨比股票危險
比股票更難賺的原因
是因為
期貨可以選擇開更高的槓桿
但是實際上
可以開更高的槓桿是更安全的
因為
就是
你可以計算你
需要放多少的總資金當保證金
例如說
你總共有
100單位的錢
那
如果你可以開17.5倍槓桿的話
等於
你只要放
你總資產6%的錢
進去當保證金
就可以交易100%的槓桿
因為你可以開17.5倍的槓桿
在現在的
保證金裡面
它是會一直改變的
就是
奇教授會很常調整保證金要收多少
然後
就是
所以你只需要放6%的錢當期貨保證金
那你其他90幾%的錢
你還是可以分散投資到各式各樣種類的資產裡面
例如說
投資到房地產
你又只需要花20%的錢
然後開5倍的槓桿
那因為可以貸款80%嘛
所以等於是說
你盡量去投資
分散你的資產到不一樣的地方
例如說
或是私人公司的股權
或者是
如果你有經營一些小公司
或者是你個人品牌
你也可以
會有你的
投資在你的公司的品牌價值
或者是收藏品
虛擬幣
當然虛擬幣
股票債券虛擬幣
跟期貨的連動性相關性
會比較高一點
但是如果你的股票債券
這些也都是會有一些比較長期的部位
或者是一些比較
跟你的期貨的那些短線策略
不要那麼連動的話
其實這樣的話
還是分散風險
所以就是
如果你把你100%的錢
全部都放進保證金裡面
然後去交易一口
也就是說
只交易一倍的不開槓桿的話
其實你的資金的整體風險
是比較高的
因為你就沒有分散投資
沒有分散投資到各種各樣的地方
這個是
就是
我實際上也是這樣做的
當然還有一個是升降級制度
就是
你自己的精神能力
可以承受你自己下幾口的大小
就是持有多大的部位去操作這個遊戲
所以
如果我知道我的能力大概就是操作幾口的話
我就是固定放這樣的保證金
然後我賺到其他錢
我就會拿去買其他的東西
例如說我現在也有一些房子
只是在收租金的
那就是
分散投資到各個地方
然後我有投資朋友的公司
就是賣金磨槍的公司
各種東西
就是
我會讓我資產更分散
那保證金不需要因此放得越來越多
好
所以就是
可以開槓
高槓桿的話
反而降低了風險
如果不能夠開槓桿
就例如說現股
當然現股還是可以融資開2.5倍槓桿
但是大部分人都是買沒有槓桿的現貨
那其實那個就更不分散
例如說
我想要買兩張的台積電
那我就需要放300萬的錢
然後一直被卡在那裡
但如果我是買一口的台積電期貨的話
我就只需要放很少的錢在這個地方
那這樣的話我的配置就可以
整體的資產配置就可以更分散更安全
所以相對於
不開槓桿去買一張
兩張
或是一張的台積電
或甚至是買台積電的零股
這個都是完全一樣的意思嘛
因為他們的比例是一樣的
好
然後
再來另外一個
我剛講的是數學上的理由
為什麼
期貨可以開滿槓桿
反而可以更安全的分散你的資金的配置
另外一個原因是心理學上的原因
就是
如果你有560萬的總資產
那現在一口大台的價值大概就是560萬
所以
如果你總資產560萬的人
你開一倍槓桿就是交易一口大台
那你只放30幾萬到保證金賬戶裡面的話
你就按不下去第二口
因為你保證金不足
如果你玩到很生氣的時候
你也買不下第二口大台
但是如果你覺得說
那這樣的話
你放30萬交易一口大台
是開17倍槓桿
這樣好危險
你放350萬保證金進去
去交易一口大台
那這樣是不到兩倍的槓桿
你覺得很安全
因為開不到兩倍的槓桿
但其實更危險
因為你給了自己一個
去下單十口的選擇
就是
你的
你的資金是一口
但是如果你越生氣
你就可以再按第二口
更生氣按四口
更生氣按八口
更生氣要按十六口的時候
發現按不下去
就改按十口
那這樣的話就非常的危險
對吧
就是讓你生氣的時候
也沒辦法交易更多口
其實這個也是有對自己一個保護
因為就是在行為經濟學上
你要就是讓自己改變
就是限制你的選擇
然後自我綁架
然後改變這個習慣的獎勵路徑這樣
反正這個是屬於減少選擇
就是不要讓自己
有機會按更多口
那反正
你其他的錢
可以先放在其他地方
那如果你真的需要補錢的時候
你可以
例如說
就是再把其他地方的錢
補一些進來
這樣也是比較安全的
好
然後再來是
就是期貨是零合遊戲
或者是付很少一點點的遊戲
那就是
每一口多單都會對應一口空單
其實可以不用拍
就是回去之後
你就密我的粉專
我就可以免費把PowerPoint給你
不是只有這一次
每一次都是
就是
每一次都可以跟我免費的要PowerPoint
所以
不需要拍那個PPT這樣
好
然後
就是
因為每一口空單都對應一口多單
那所以
所有人的平倉損益
就是不扣手續費跟稅的話
加起來是零
那當然
期貨有非常微薄的手續費跟稅
一點點而已
那
但那個都是
我剛剛講的嘛
低於一千分之一
就是
在你整個輸贏的
的比例是非常非常低的
所以
基本上
它就像是撲克牌
或者是一些
很接近零合的複合遊戲一樣
就是
你學習更多的理論知識
你就會輸走桌子上
其他靠感覺玩
完全不知道理論知識的人的錢
當然它短期
可能可以靠運氣
贏一點點錢
但是
繼續玩的話
它就會輸更多的錢
所以
就是
如果要參與
股票期貨遊戲的話
那基本上還是
先學習足夠的理論知識再玩
這個就跟說
要不要考大學一樣
就是
如果有讀書的人
就去考大學
如果沒有讀書的人
那就不要去考大學
因為如果他
去考大學
當書籤玩家的話
那他就會
浪費掉四年的壽命
那四年的壽命
也是非常昂貴的
好
然後
我們講一下
交易者三元素
Trader Triad
我自己幫他取了一個
英文名字
就是
因為在醫學裡面
常常會有什麼什麼
三個
就會叫什麼什麼
Tri-Aid
那所以我就取一個
Trader Triad
感覺是一個
很學術的名字這樣
好
然後Trader Triad
就是說
如果你要成為一個
好的交易者
成功的交易者的話
你會需要
數學邏輯
然後再來是資金
然後還有情緒控制
那這三個
你都要有
然後做得越好的話
你就會把這個
交易者這個件事情
做得更好
然後呢
就是
數學邏輯其實
還是最重要的
就是
大部分
桌上的玩家
他們的問題都是
數學邏輯這個地方有問題
而不是說
資金或情緒控制有問題
但是
在市場上面
大部分的人都覺得
自己輸錢
是情緒控制的問題
這就像是說
因為這是一個
猜數字的遊戲
就像是很多人都去參加一個
數學比賽
數學
考試
然後
他們出來之後
他們就說
啊
那個微積分考得這麼爛
因為我心態沒有控制好
這個顯然就不是那個問題
是因為
他根本就不會
他說
哇
上一題是C
下一題是B
我心態控制好
下一題就選對了
這個是一個波浪的規律
C B A D
怎麼沒有想到
這根本就不是那個問題
就是重的問題
重的問題是在於
你沒有
你沒有控制好
就是不是控制性問題
是因為你根本就沒有讀書
沒有學習足夠的理論知識
那就是
因為
大部分的魚類玩家
就是
不會玩的人
我們叫做Fish
就是魚類玩家
就是Fish
很容易看那些
Pro職業玩家說
啊
這一次
沒有發揮好
心態真的很重要
交易最難的是心態
那為什麼職業選手會這樣講
為什麼
打到季後賽的那個職業運動員
他們可能會說
啊
心態真的很重要
就是
因為他們是
已經
把很多正確的事情
都已經學會了
然後
要看他們的心態
能不能夠
執行百分之多少
他們學會的那些正確的事情
例如說他們
已經可以做到95分
然後再乘上一個
他們心態可以表現的分數
可能再乘以90%
0.59
所以他的表現
就沒有辦法95分
會再低一點點
但是
大部分的魚類玩家
他們的問題
就不是心態的問題
他們可能會的姿勢
就只有10分
那不管乘以多少
都還是非常的低
好
那當然他這個也是有心理學的原因
就是
如果
你在一個事情上面表現不好的話
結果
原因是因為
你沒有足夠的知識
這個你就會自我懷疑
是不是我這個人不夠好
可是如果你是說
這個心態最難
交易最難的
就是克服心理
心魔真的很難克服
這個是人性
你就會覺得說
這個好像也不是因為我自己很笨的問題
但這個方式會自我安慰
但是
就是會阻礙人進步
然後
就是
很多人輸了很多錢之後
他們就會
發一個
那種
畢業文
然後感嘆說
什麼
我就學到了一件事情
不要預測高點
心態真的很重要
但其實他們就是
什麼都沒有學到
就是
他們應該要學到的是
他們做的那些事情有哪些錯誤
那如果是說什麼
不要預測下一題的答案是多少
這個
基本上
就是
它根本不是那個遊戲的重點
然後
這些人就會很容易得出一個結論
就是說
數學考試真的很危險
勸大家不要參加數學考試
也不要學數學
我跟你講
當年我就是學數學才畢業
就是
會跟大家講這些
那
其實他們就反而打走了
自己有機會提升自己階級的機會
因為其實
到一定的程度之後
我們還是要參與
錢滾錢的數學遊戲
才有辦法提升階級
就是如果還是在
領薪水的話
大致上就是
最高就是中產階級這樣
好
然後
只要講的是
如果是要成為頂端1%的話
那最重要的是
學習正確的理論知識
那是到
要成為世界排名前級
才是心態比較重要
只是因為大部分人
很容易看到
世界排名前級的人
在發表心得
那他們發表心得
都是心態很重要
然後大部分人
就是
因為其實
畢竟
講心態很重要
聽起來就是
哇
這個人
進界很高啊
高手
高手都是講心態很重要
你看
如果是講說
數學很重要
聽起來好俗氣喔
心態很重要
哎呦
進界很高
修為很高
所以大家也會比較想要講
心態很重要這件事情
那不過就是
像我剛講的
大部分人的問題都是
根本不知道正確的action是什麼
那也不是說
他已經把表格記得超清楚
然後什麼應該做
什麼不應該做
他都知道了
只是心態不好
沒做到
好
然後
我們
就是每一次演講
都還是
會要講的一些
我覺得最重要的
基本概念
所以如果
聽過
或者是看過前面的
以前的影片的話
就是我都還是會再講一次
好
就是在
那個
投資
就是股票市場裡面
有一個最重要的
一個基本概念
就是要
設置的策略
盡量要是
長停損短停力的策略
當然如果你有
利用特殊的遊戲規則
有些很特別的考量的話
可能可以不這樣
但大部分的情況下
尤其是大部分人做的應該
不是攻擊特定的遊戲規則
而是一些波段
各式各樣的東西
都是長停損
這個寫錯了
是長停力短停損
好
回去我會改一下powerpoint
這邊是寫錯
是長停力短停損
然後它的原因
基本的假設是因為
股市會有延續性
如果一家好的公司
他最近賺錢了
他以後會更容易賺錢
這個是寫相反的
是長停力短停損
所以一家不好的公司
但是他如果在下跌
通常有一個在下跌的原因
所以他通常
比較有可能繼續下跌
那其實只要
比較有可能一點點的話
那長停力短停損
就會是比較好的
因為就是
有延續性的話
你就要更長的持有
就是正在發生的那件事情的部位
那這叫做更長的持有正確的部位
雖然他聽起來很像是一個廢話
但是呢
因為他跟我們人性自然而然會做的事情是相反的
所以必須要特別的提醒
就是你制定的策略要是一個
最好是一個非常明確的進出場策略
讓自己去正確的執行到很長的停力
和配一個比較短的停損
那在實際上
我們人類人性會想要做的事情是相反的
例如說這個叫做value curve
價值曲線
它的x軸是前
然後y軸
就是你內心覺得的爽度
utility
心理價值
那如果你定的一個策略是
200點停力
100點停損的話
那你在已經賺100塊的時候
你會想說
如果現在有一半的機會
從賺100塊變賺200塊
另外一半的機會是賺100塊變成歸零
你會很容易覺得說
賺100塊到賺200塊增加的快樂比較少
但是賺100塊變成歸零的損失的快樂比較多
所以
100塊的時候你就會心理上比較想要提早停力
那這個是因為
這個邊際效益利減的關係
你先賺到的第一百萬
跟再賺100萬
的感受
第二個賺到的100萬
的快樂會沒有第一個100萬賺到的多
就是如果你現在有一個選項是
你就是只賺100萬
或者是
可以一半的機率賺200萬
一半的機率是零
那大部分的人應該是會想選
就是穩穩的就是只賺100萬這樣
那在
輸錢的時候會是相反的
如果你現在有兩個選項
一個是固定輸100萬
一個是
一半的機會輸200萬
一半的機會是零
那大部分的人就會變成去趨向風險
就是
選擇
一半機會零
一半機會輸200萬的這個選項
因為
輸100萬跟輸200萬的
痛苦程度是比較接近的
這個也是因為邊際效益低減的關係
所以
如果你定了一個策略是
200停力100停損的話
但是人性的感覺
會想要在100的時候就停力
然後100的時候不停損
放到-200的時候
那
這個是
人性會
自然而然會發生的事情
然後
它更底層的原因
就是因為邊際效益低減
然後畫出來的這個
value curve
然後發展出這個展望理論
那
所以
我們人
如果是按照人性來做的話
我們會很容易
就是長停損
短停力這樣子
好
然後
其實如果是
就是不停損
然後加碼攤平
倍倍攤平的這個方式
其實也是屬於一種
就是長停損
短停力
等於是你賺了一點點就跑
然後
輸的時候會越輸越多
而且你持有的時間還更久
而且持有的倉位還更大
那這樣
這個是人性很容易做的
就是你輸一塊錢的時候
你就再攤平
輸
會再變輸更多
然後你再更加碼攤平
金字爬加碼攤平進去
但是實際上
應該要做的事情
是正好相反
就是
我們應該是
把輸錢的倉位全部都砍掉
然後
把輸錢的股票賣掉之後
那些錢拿去買
賺錢的股票
其實
就是我最近才跟其中一個朋友
講這件事
他說他的其中幾個股票
就是
被套牢
然後賠了很多
然後他反而把
AI的股票賣掉
然後去加碼套牢的股票
因為他那些落袋為安
就把暴漲的股票賣掉
然後結果反而去買那些
就是傳統產業的股票
然後結果
那些什麼鴻海啊
或者是
就是代工啊
就是各種暴漲的股票
反而被他賣掉
然後結果他買了一些
漲不動的股票
這個是人性很容易會做到完全相反的情況
所以這是為什麼
我們不要靠感覺去交易
就是剛好我們人性的感覺
在玩這個股票市場的數學遊戲的時候
剛好就是會去做比較差的事情
所以我們就是要去學習各種理論
然後我們會做比較好的事情
好
然後再來是升降級制度
升降級制度是
除了在
期貨
在其他的
金錢遊戲
或者是其他做的事情的
重要程度上
我們都可以使用的一個方法
那就是
簡單來說他的邏輯是
如果你做這件事做得好的話
你就
投更多的錢到這個地方
然後如果你發現你這件事情做的
沒有那麼理想那麼好的話
你就降低在這個地方的下注尺度
那用這個方式我們就可以找到
適合自己的下注尺度
就知道自己買股票期貨應該要下多大
因為大部分的人是
沒有辦法按照凱利公司去下
按照凱利公司去下的話
你可能常常需要承受
損失百分之三十、百分之四十的總資產
那這個人很容易心理上
沒有辦法承受這些事情
然後就
就on-tiered
然後就會去亂交易
那
升降級制度
就
固定是從最小的
雖然現在有微台
但我覺得可以從一小台
作為最小的下注尺度
來慢慢的往上去升級
那就是下注
你就是用一小台去做
你現在學到的東西
然後如果你做得好的話
就在升級變成下兩小台
那如果做得好的話
再升級下一大台
那不要有什麼一大台加一小台
這樣的策略等級
因為這個Level
就等於是你要去按兩個閃電下單畫面
那這個是非常麻煩的
所以基本上我會覺得
一大台再來就是升級成兩大台
然後三大台、四大台
然後就是
大部分的人應該都沒有辦法升級到超過五大台以上
這因為大部分人還是會想要把就是
你的那個賺賠去對應到就是你的工資收入
然後就大部分的人會覺得一點的胎值
如果是五大台的話
一點就是一千塊
那一千塊應該超過大部分的人一個小時可以賺的錢
所以他們會覺得一秒鐘這樣跳好幾點
一秒鐘跳好幾千塊
內心會很容易
就是在輸錢的時候
玩到非常的情緒生氣這樣
那這樣就不太好
升降級制度可以幫助你找到你
適合的
不會玩到生氣的最大下注尺度是多少
然後你就在這個尺度下注
當然你沒有辦法確定你在這個
例如說兩大台的下注尺度一定不會生氣
所以如果你在兩大台下注尺度
玩到生氣發生了
你就要把自己降級變成一大台
那基本上我只是簡略講這個制度
其實情緒管理制度還有很多更明確的規則
那這個就是控制風險的一些心理學的方法
所以基本上除了學習數學策略之外
我們還是會學習很多風險控制的方法
就是讓你有很好的數學策略
而且有一個風險控制方法
讓你可以很好的執行這些數學策略
所以這個心理學跟數學
在股票期貨這個遊戲裡面都是蠻重要的
這樣
好然後再來是守護者制度跟情緒管理制度
好那基本上就是也是我以前的影片有講過幾次的
就是守護者就是一個風險控制人員
然後他可以幫助你管控你的風險
然後這個情緒管理制度也是有很多很多的規定這樣子
好這個看起來看起來很多人其實聽過了
就表示這個點是很謝謝大家
就是表示大家聽過很多很多次我的講座
好那所以我們就這段就可以先不再講一次
再講一次其實沒關係
好那我就
總結一下就是我這次的講座其實有很多的內容不一樣
就是我希望用遊戲漏洞玩家的這個角度
來讓大家感受到我們玩遊戲
如果是用這個尋找遊戲漏洞來制定特殊的事件交易的這種策略的話
它是一種很特別的遊戲類型
然後它可以達到很低風險高報酬的效果
然後如果就是有興趣學習這種類似的東西的話
可以去沒有我粉專也可以聯絡悅寧
都可以看你跟誰比較熟
好那就這樣
然後待會兒悅寧會上台講二三十分鐘
然後最後會有一些時間可以跟工作人員問問題
看你想要諮詢一些東西還是什麼東西都可以
好那就這樣謝謝大家
謝謝大家